you've produced over 40 short films yeah
yeah and that's starting from age 15
until sometime like late in my 20s yeah
most of them I I kind of I kind of had a
plan like I said before I started out
with like little five-minute shorts and
then sort of built to like a 10 minute
short and then to a 20 minute and then
40 minutes and then you know eventually
my first feature film and yeah a lot of
those were mostly for myself like
somebody released but most of them I
just wanted to focus on particular
aspects of filmmaking so for instance
with one of my just focus on composition
you know like another might be just
lighting another might be sound another
might be movement or being able to frame
action a particular way yeah and so like
yeah I always sort of approached every
aspect of filmmaking from a separately
like I'm gonna give you guys a tip I'm
gonna give you a really important piece
of information like one of my mentors
gave me and it was a way to sort of like
in the beginning when you're trying to
train your eye as far as cinematography
this was a tip I got that sort of took
my my cinematography from here to here
like overnight so so what you do is you
get a binder like a five ring binder or
something like that you go online you
search Google you look for movies that
are like 100 million dollars or more
like in terms of budget right you find
close-ups you find two shots you find
masters you find all these different
frames like still still frames from all
these films the reason you choose
million-dollar films because they can
afford like the top cinematographers in
the world right so you you section off
your binder let's say you want close-ups
so in this section you put maybe five
examples of close-ups another section
you put another five examples of a
two-shot or whatever over the shoulder
whatever and you you fill it up with
those different frames and different
sections and so from there let's say
you're a cinematographer you kind of
knew it you just start out and you may
not really know how to frame subjects
that great just yet so what you do is
every time you shoot you set up your
tripod you set up your camera you adjust
your frame the way you think it should
be the way you think it should look
let's say you have two people having a
conversation whatever the case is and
you want to do an over-the-shoulder shot
you adjust that frame to where you think
it should look right then you'd take out
your bond and you go to over the
shoulder shots and then you hold that
bond there up you next to your your
frame and then you begin to adjust your
frame based on the composition you see
in those frames and so as you do that
it's going to slowly begin to train your
eye to have a more cinematic composition
you know I mean say that's just a little
tip right there yeah I'm sorry
you